four times the daily number of cases as
we have
over the summer through january 27th
25.4 million cova 19 cases have been
reported to cdc
during the week of january 21st to
january 27th
the seven-day average of news cases
decreased
16.6 to 161
832 per day the seven-day average of new
hospital admissions of patients with
covet 19
during the week of january 20th to
january 26
decreased by 14 to 12 720 per day
however over 99 000 people were
hospitalized with covet 19
on january 26th 427
6226 deaths have been reported
since january 22nd through january 22nd
2020. during the week of january 21st
to january 27th the seven-day average
number of deaths
increased 7.5 to 3
277 per day and yesterday we saw
our sixth day of over 4 000
deaths we continue to remain concerned
about the emergence of variants in the
united states and are rapidly ramping up
surveillance and sequencing activities
as we work to closely monitor and
identify variants
as they emerge any information we have
we will then share with you as rapidly
as possible
the b117 variant that was first detected
in the uk
has now been confirmed in 379 cases
in 29 states as of january 27th
yesterday south carolina public health
officials
notified the public about the first two
documented cases of the b-1351 variant
which was officially first detected in
south africa and
now in the united states these cases
were identified
identified in different parts of the
state and not
believed to be epidemiologically linked
they each did not have any travel
history we are still learning more about
their exposures
and earlier this week minnesota
identified the first u.s
case of the p1 variant this is the
variant that originally emerged in
brazil
cdc will continue communicating with
international state
and local partners to monitor the
presence and impact of variants in the
united states
and around the world and we are actively
working with
national reference laboratories state
health departments and researchers
across the country to improve our
understanding of these variants
and how they it may impact the pandemic
we also know viruses mutate and they
tend to mutate in ways that are
advantageous to the virus we expected
this
and this is why i feel compelled to
underscore for you
the need for each of us to remain
steadfast in our commitment
to taking all of the appropriate steps
to protect ourselves and our communities
you're going to hear me say this a lot
so here it is wear a mask
stay six feet apart avoid crowds and
poorly ventilated spaces
also now is not the time to travel
if you choose to travel please follow
the cdc guidelines and be aware that you
must wear a mask as you travel
and what is your turn please blow up
your sleeve and get vaccinated
if we do all these things there is less
virus spreading
and the conditions can that produce
virus
by variants are lessened and before i
turn it over to dr fauci
i would like to just address school
reopenings which i know has also been in
the news a lot this week
cdc continues to recommend that k-12
schools be the last setting to close
after all other mitigations have
measures have been employed
and the first to reopen when they can do
so safely
accumulating data suggests school
settings do not result in rapid spread
of covet 19
when mitigation measures are followed
including masking
decreasing density and proper
ventilation
implementing community-based strategies
that reduce transmission when there is a
lot of virus
in a particular area is also important
to supporting the safe
reopening of schools but we recognize
many
communities lack sufficient capacity to
do all that it is needed
that is why it is essential that the
guidance
tools and resources called for in the
national strategy for the kova 19
response
and the american rescue plan are
provided to communities
thank you i look forward to taking your
questions in a few minutes and i will
now turn it over to dr fauci
dr fauci thank you very much dr wolinski
well as alluded to by uh uh andy
slabbitt
uh this past week and particularly the
past 24 hours have been really
interesting and i think value added to
the
uh issue of vaccine protection
in the government attempt to contain
this outbreak
in previous briefings i had mentioned
that the federal government had been
involved in the development
and or facilitation of three
separate platforms of vaccines one was
the mrna
the other were vector either an
adenovector or chimp vector and the
other was the soluble
recombinant proteins we all know now
of the recent data that came uh with
regard to moderna
and fisa with their mrna showing a 94 to
95
efficacy and a very very good efficacy
against advanced or severe disease
over the last 24 hour there have been
the announcements of two
other trials that represent two
additional
platforms one is the soluble protein
platform in a study that came out of the
uk
using uh from the company novavax
and the other one that we discussed this
morning at a press conference at the nih
was the johnson or johnson and johnson i
don't know
26 trial that took place
in the united states in south africa
and in brazil and the results really are
very
encouraging let me just very briefly
outline for them
for you and then maybe make a couple of
comments regarding
nuances of the study in the study
that was just reported by johnson
johnson and johnson it was a trial using
their ad 26 and the overall vaccine
efficacy
in in this in the study was 66
but for the united states it was 72
percent now the important issue because
the first thing people do
is compare a 72 percent efficacy
with the previously reported and other
uh trials of 94 to 95
that is true but when one looks at the
potential
impact on a very important aspect of
what we look at carefully
is namely severe disease that overall
in the united states in south africa
and in brazil the overall efficacy for
severe disease
was 85 and in fact
in the study including in the south
african isolate
there were essentially no
hospitalizations or deaths
in the vaccine group whereas in the
placebo group
there were so this really tells us
that we have now a value-added
additional
vaccine candidate that will of course as
happens with every candidate
will present the details of their data
to the fda but i want to point out that
this has
important potential and real
implications both
domestically and globally because as
many of you are aware of
this is a single shot vaccine in which
you start to see efficacy
anywhere from seven to ten days
following
the first and only shot it is very very
good with regard to cold chain
requirements namely
requiring only a refrigerator it is
inexpensive
and the company is capable of making
doses in the
in the numbers of billions of note
and this is something that relates to
what dr wilinsky
just said we are being faced with
variance
we're all aware of the variance that we
knew
dominated in the uk the 117 the 351
in south africa and other variants such
as the p1
in brazil when these variants were first
recognized it became clear that we had a
look at
in vitro in the test tube whether the
antibodies that were induced
by the vaccines that we had available
would actually
neutralize these new mutants and it was
reported in several
pre-print journals over the past couple
of weeks
that although it diminished particularly
the troublesome
south african isolate although it
diminished
the efficacy of the antibodies it still
was not
below the cut off where you would expect
some degree of efficacy
but what we know now from this study
namely the j and j and the novovac study
that antigenic variation i.e
mutations that lead to different lineage
do have clinical consequences because as
you can see
even though the long-range effect in the
sense of
severe disease is still handled
reasonably well by the vaccines
this is a wake-up call to all of us that
we will be dealing
as the virus uses its devices to evade
pressure particularly immunological
pressure
that we will continue to see the
evolution of mutants so we
that means that we as a government the
companies all of us that are in this
together
will have to be nimble to be able to
just adjust
readily to make versions of the vaccine
that actually are specifically directed
towards whatever mutation is actually
prevalent at any given time and finally
this all tells us that it is an
incentive
to do what we've been saying all along
to vaccinate as many people as we can
as quickly as we possibly can because
mutations occur
because the virus has a playing field as
it were
to mutate if you stop that and stop the
replication viruses cannot mutate
if they don't replicate and that's the
reason to continue to do what we're
doing
namely intensify our ability and our
implementation of to vaccinate as many
people
as possible as quickly as possible so
now i'll hand it back
to andy slabbit andy thank you dr fauci
before i turn it over to all of you for
some questions i want to offer a few
updates
and a sense of the action and activities
and our progress
against executing our plan to defeat
defeat covet 19.
one of the core elements of our plan is
accelerating the process
of vaccinating the country to protect
people from covet 19
as quickly and as safely as possible
for the past week our seven-day average
number of shots administered
was 1.2 million per day
we view this number of 1 million doses
per day
as a base to build from in the coming
days
weeks and months in total
we've now delivered 48 million doses
and 26 million of those doses have been
administered
as i have said before we're facing two
challenges
the first is increasing the supply of
vaccines
safely and more rapidly and speeding up
the time
it takes to administer them efficiently
and importantly equitably
i want to call out seven states
that have already provided first
vaccinations
to more than 10 percent of their adult
populations
alaska west virginia new mexico
connecticut north dakota oklahoma
and south dakota well done
so we have taken steps to announce
last week that we will increase supply
week over week by 16 percent
and vastly improve the predictability of
ordering vaccines
by giving everyone a three-week forward
window
into how many vaccines they will be
getting delivered
and we announced plans to purchase 200
million
additional vaccines which means that
no matter what happens with other
approvals
we will have sufficient supply to
vaccinate the country
we're also taking steps to speed the
vaccination administration process
at the president's direction fema has
has increased its support to states
tribes and territories for vaccination
sites
fema is providing nearly one billion
dollars to support vaccination sites in
states and territories
more than 200 fema staff members are on
the ground today
providing logistical support in eight
states
and the agency is providing federal
equipment
and supplies to support states across
the country
in addition we're getting more
vaccinators into the field to continue
to
escalate the pace of vaccinations
yesterday
the department of health and human
services amended the prep
act declaration to permit
recently retired doctors and nurses
to administer covet 19 vaccines and
permit
anyone currently licensed to vaccinate
within their home state
that's doctors nurses emts
to be able to administer shots across
state lines
we're looking at every possible step to
make it easier to get more vaccinations
out in the field
we encourage individuals to contact
their local and state health departments
their local medical reserve corps unit
to sign up to volunteer
if they're qualified and today the
acting
health and human services secretary will
continue the activation
of the u.s public health service
commission corps
he's requesting public health service
officers from all available categories
to support national covet 19 vaccination
efforts
i want to also touch on our efforts to
make the workplace safer
the department of labor announced that
its occupational safety and health
administration
or osha has issued stronger worker
safety guidance to help employers and
workers
implement a coronavirus mitigation
program and better identify risks
which could lead to exposure and
infection
ensuring the health and safety of all of
our country's workers is a national
priority
and a moral and economic imperative
health care workers and other essential
workers
many of whom are people of color
immigrants have put their lives on the
line
during the coronavirus pandemic
and this updated guidance provides a
roadmap for businesses
to protect the health of their workers
now one of the purposes of these
briefings
is to demonstrate the transparency
that's within our national plan
and so i want to close by mentioning
some of the steps we're taking to
improve public access
the information they should have at
their fingertips
to stay safe this week we released
previously
non-public data on the pandemic
trends across all 50 states in detail
this detailed information was previously
reserved solely for governors
and it is now available to everybody to
see
these will be weekly reports publicly
posted online
so our team is working hard to make the
process more transparent
and easier for the public to understand
beginning with these brave briefings and
the very clear messages
from dr zwelinsky and fauci
so let me turn and spend the balance of
our time taking questions
for dr wolinski dr fauci and myself
great thanks andy um right now we have
time for a couple of questions
um if you have not already you can go
ahead and raise your hand on the zoom
feature
first up we're going to go to
christopher rowland at the washington
post
uh yes thank you thanks for doing the uh
briefing um on the subject
of uh the low dead space syringes
i was wondering um what percentage of
the administration
kits now are being sent out with the
visor vaccine contain those specialized
units
how many millions more do you need to
get to 100
and what companies are being ordered to
procure more under the dpa
and also on the state alliance and
pfizer's credit
uh our state allotments um based on five
doses in the vial or six and as far as
they're getting credit for all six doses
thanks for the question and at risk of
somebody coming back and correcting
my answer i believe the answer is 100
and they're getting credit for six
precisely because uh everybody should
now have the tools to be able to get
the sixth visor dose out uh that's
that's thanks to the work of our dpa and
supply chain team
next question great next we'll go to
caitlin collins at cnn
thank you i have two questions actually
one on these new variants that we're
seeing and the expectation
seems to be that they could really start
to have an impact on cases by march
maybe gain a foothold by april and
become the dominant
uh cases that we're seeing so what
specifically is the administration doing
to stop that from happening
beyond recommending the people's social
distance and wear masks
well let me turn uh first to dr fauci
to talk about um the science behind
these variants and what
what what is likely to happen or what we
know or what we believe and then
to dr wolinski after that so she can
discuss uh the
actions we're taking as a country and
the actions we expect americans to take
to help
uh help with your your question thank
you
oh well caitlyn there are a number of
variants that
we're concerned about and one that is
quite
well established already uh in the
united states
and that is the uh 117 that is
in about 28 or 29 states and
more than 315 cases that have all been
uh uh reported as you alluded to the
fact is
that when you have a virus that has
ability to uh transmit more efficiently
than the wild type in the community
sooner or later by pure viral dynamics
itself it will become
more dominant than the wild type
so we have that already there we have a
situation
where there have now been reported in
very specific places in south carolina
for example
the isolate or the mutant that is the
three five
one from
uh dominant in south africa again that
seems to have
a very good fitness for in the sense
of being dominant is unclear by now
the projection that is made with regard
to the uk
is that probably by the end of march the
beginning of april
it actually will become more dominant in
this country
as i mentioned at the very end of my
remarks
uh i'll leave it to in a moment to uh dr
wolinski to talk a bit about
what we're doing from a surveillance
another standpoint but
the fundamental principle of getting
people vaccinated as quickly
and as efficiently as you possibly can
will always be the best way
to prevent the further evolution of any
mutant
because when you do that you prevent
replication
and replication is essential for
mutation
so over to you dr wolinski thank you dr
faucian for that question
um so there are numerous things that we
are doing
as dr fauci noted the the prevention
measures the mitigation measures for
variants are actually exactly the same
regardless of what variant you have
we have scaled up surveillance
dramatically just in the last 10 days in
fact
but our plans for scaling up
surveillance are even more than what
we've done so far so we have
partnerships with commercial labs
we are now asking surveillance from
every single state at least 750
um surveillance strings per week
and we have seven collaborations across
universities to scale up surveillance to
the thousands per week
so that we can get a foothold just to
see whether these projections of having
this take hold
by the middle of march or late um middle
to late march
are actually true um what we're also
doing is offering support to the states
that have identified these surveillances
specifically south carolina with the 351
variant
reaching out um to help with vaccination
as vaccination is again one of these
things we need to do
with resources for increased testing
increased surveillance
um as well as increased resources for
vaccination and
funding so we're working hard to make
sure that we can actually do the
mitigation measures the vaccination
do the surveillance and then finally we
have cross-agency collaborations with
cdc nih arda dod so that when we get
these strains we can do the science and
understand the impact
of these variants on our vaccines as
well as on our therapeutics
let me do one more comment uh look
if we as a country want to turbo charge
our efforts at sequencing which i
believe
should be a shared bipartisan
perspective
we can do that and what we need is the
congress
to quickly pass the american rescue plan
which contains the resources necessary
to get all of our very
very talented people around the country
who are
world experts at sequencing to get on
this as quickly as possible so i
couldn't urge
people to people and the congress to be
more more focused on the american rescue
plan than i can given the state of the
variants
maybe if i could make one more point in
that is that um
by the time someone has symptoms gets a
test
has a positive result and we get the
sequence
our opportunity for doing real case
control
and and and contact tracing is is
largely gone
and so i think and i believe that we
should be treating every case as if it's
a variant
um during this pandemic right now thank
you thank you for the question
next great now we'll go to ed o'keefe at
cvs
and i think you can speak
all right and we'll we'll try to come
back to you uh in the meantime
let's go to caroline chen
hi thanks for taking my question um this
is a question for
uh both dr wolenski and dr fauci so when
epidemiologists talk about herd immunity
they often say about
70 or 80 of the population is the goal
given that about 20 of the u.s
population is children
do you think it's important to have
eligibility expanded to children for
vaccination as soon as possible
and if so what are um what is being done
to
to get to that goal yes
that's a very good question and in in
the
candidates that we're talking about now
certainly though modern
and and the fires of the two that have
been given the eua
we've already started on what's called
an age de-escalation testing
but that means that you start off for
example we know
with one of the vaccines it's 16 and
then one is 18 years old we're going to
go down from 16 to 12 from 12 to 9
and what you do because you don't want
to have to and and i'll explain why in a
moment
to go through an efficacy uh
trial where you're involving tens of
thousands of children to show efficacy
what you can do
is in a much smaller trial measured in
hundreds to a couple of thousands
to do what we call safety in a phase 2a
for immunogenicity and if you can show
that it's safe
and that in fact it induces the kind of
response
that is reflective of the protection
namely the correlate
of immunity what you can do is then
bridge that
to the efficacy data that you got from
the 30 000
trial with modena and the 44 000 trial
that we did with pfizer so in direct
answer to your question
over the next couple of months we will
be doing trials in a
in an age de-escalation manner so that
hopefully
by the time we get to the late spring
and early summer we will have children
being able to be vaccinated according to
the fda's guidance
thank you dr olinsky do you want to add
anything
i i was just going to add our current
data from schools from summer camps and
whatnot
also suggests that the children not only
have decreased rates of symptoms but
have decreased rates of transmissibility
those estimates for herd immunity are
very much based on rates of
transmissibility
and so um what pertains to herd immunity
among adults may be different among
children
thank you next question great we have
time for two more
uh we are going to go to sharon la
fournier at new york times
thank you can you hear me yes um so
dr fauci said that we're going to have
to make new versions of the existing
vaccines to combat the variants
and the vaccine scene makers have shown
that they can design
vaccines but where is the extra
manufacturing capacity going to come
from aren't the vaccine makers already
tapped out
making the existing vaccines so what's
the plan for making revised vaccines and
booster
shots on top of that thanks for the
question i think this question speaks to
a larger
issue because i think you could have
asked that question with a number of
different permutations
and that's the issue of contingency
planning and making sure we have
sufficient vaccines
sufficient manufacturing capacity and
enough space
in our contracts to be able to make
adjustments on the fly
and i would tell you that the department
of health and human services
the fda the the team led by dr kessler
are currently hard at work answering all
of those questions
so i will not use these briefings to
talk about non-public information about
specific companies all i can tell you is
those are exactly the right factors
that we are thinking about and i think
the the to make a broader point the
teamwork
between everybody here between the nih
the um cdc the fda
uh and then and then our ability to to
understand what those factors are
and turn it into actual actionable plans
with the manufacturers
is really important and i've been
incredibly impressed uh at least so far
with that
great and we'll we'll send our last
question to yamiche at
people
you cut off uh
hi um it's yummy shall center with pbs
thanks so much for taking my question
can you hear me yes i can okay um
i have two questions the first is it
sounded like you were saying that we're
vaccinating about a million people daily
i wonder if you can talk about what the
goal would be that the average goal
would be
and how quickly we ramp up to that
average like what would be a better
average
and then i have a second question after
that well so with
our seven day average is 1.2 million
per day as i said we view where we are
today
as a floor not a ceiling um what we have
tasked our team
with is as many vaccines as possible
into as many arms as possible
there are two constraints right now the
first is just continuing
week after week to press to increase
productions and find opportunities
as they exist that is a slow process
that doesn't happen
overnight the second where i think there
is opportunity
is to turn those vaccines produced into
actual vaccinations
more rapidly and we've announced a
number of steps to do that
so i'm not going to put out a different
number today on what i'd like to see
other than to tell you that every day
when the number comes out
comes out all of us are breathlessly
awaiting the number and looking for as
high a number as possible of course
i know you have another question amish
and then i wanted to ask about the
two-thirds of cases in los angeles
county it's it's been reported
came out in the last two months have
been reported in the last two months
um one fact one study said that the
factor was this recent
coronavirus surge of the new variant cal
2.2
0c what more do we know about the la
variant and
what does that tell us about other big
cities should should we expect maybe a
new york
new orleans variant how how how does
what is la teaching us about what our
big cities might be
experiencing thank you dr fauci do you
want to take that one
yeah sure well what it tells us is what
i alluded to in one of my prior
comments that when you have a
significant amount
and we certainly have that now and i've
had that
very much so over the past couple of
months with the very
steep slope of acceleration of cases
that we've seen
is that the virus will continue to
mutate
and will mutate for its own selective
advantage
so if you have a lot of cases in los
angeles and you have this mutant that
you referred to
you can be almost certain that as long
as there's a lot of virus
circulating in the community there will
be the evolution of mutants
because that's what viruses do
particularly
rna viruses and that's what i was
referring to just a moment ago
you're giving the virus an opportunity
to adapt so when people make an immune
response against it
particularly in someone like that might
be immunosuppressed where the virus
stays in that person for a longer period
of time
it gives the virus the chance to adapt
to the forces in this case the immune
response
that's trying to get rid of it and
that's where you get mutations so if the
question you were asking which is very
relevant
is that what do we think is happening in
other cities
i think what the underlying issues that
are going on
in california and los angeles very
likely are taking place
throughout the country which is one of
the reason why as dr walensky has said
that we are really ratcheting up our
genomic surveillance
capability and our ability to get that
information in real time
doctor anything you'd like to add or is
that yeah okay i think we got it okay
so i think what we're saying
collectively is
let's not be quite such polite hosts to
this virus
let's turn the tide uh and do like other
countries
who do everything possible to shut out
the growth of this virus
and make sure it's not welcome well
thank you all for attending
the briefing i hope that this is useful
to you
we intend to continue to do these every
monday wednesday and friday
with the same group and we will bring
others on as well
so if you have any feedback on how we
can continue to share
this information with the public please
let us know thank you have a great
weekend
you